bonjour puisqu'à thévenot bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes au porte parole de la majorité
présidentielle au conseil régional d'île
de france est également candidate aux
législatives dans la 8e circonscription
des hauts-de-seine où vous êtes avec
nous pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale qui est représenté aujourd'hui
par le groupe ebra des journaux de l'est
de la france avec vous fabris avaient
sardon bonjour bonjour alexandre prisca
thévenon on va commencer par évoquer
forcément le stade de france et ce
fiasco cet échec dans l'organisation de
la finale de la coupe d'europe de
football samedi soir à saint denis au
stade de france avec des violences des
milliers de personnes munies de faux
billets qui ont essayé de s'introduire
dans le stade des forces de sécurité
débordé également des petits problèmes
de communication après de la part du
ministère du ministère de l'intérieur on
en parlera c'est quand même inquiétant
pour notre pays à un an de la coupe du
monde de rugby 2023 et à deux ans des
jeux olympiques alors rappelons déjà que
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il ya
des événements qui sont organisés en
france d'un point de vue sportif mais
également au stade de france et que
malheureusement oui c'est la première
fois qu'on a ce genre d'événement est ce
genre de retomber par rapport à un
évènement que tout le monde attendait
donc est ce que la fête a été gâchée oui
elle a été gâchée mais si elle a été
gâchée on peut voir que nous avons
certains responsables politiques qui ont
en profité pour venir danser au rythme
de leur vieille rengaine et quand je dis
certaines personnalités politiques je
parle par exemple du rassemblement
national avec jordan bardella qui tout
de suite s'est engouffré pour dire que
c'était la faute à l'immigration et puis
de l'autre côté nous avons là et les fit
avec monsieur mélenchon qui lui est
parti tout de suite pour pointer du
doigt nos forces de l'ordre être
responsable politique ce n'est pas
passer son temps à chercher des
coupables mais à trouver des solutions
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui ce matin la ministre des
sports a réuni va réunir pardon
l'ensemble des parties prenantes l'uefa
la fédération française de football la
préfecture de police du 93 la ville de
saint denis mais également les
organisateurs du stade de france parce
que oui nous deux on trouver des
solutions pour que ces incidents qui se
sont passées et qui sont inadmissibles
ne se reproduise pas dans deux ans aux
jo de 2024 mais également dans un an
pour le rugby alors quand on analyse les
dysfonctionnements de cet événement est
ce que la préfecture de police de paris
le ministère de l'intérieur ont fait des
erreurs dans le dispositif de sécurité
de cette finale je pense que le
dispositif de sécurité était là bien
présent il est en renfort de
l'organisation rappelons le ce ne sont
pas eux qui organisent les entrées est
venu au dans le stade de france
maintenant je pense que je n'y étais pas
c'est très compliqué pour moi de venir
vous faire une analyse très pointue et
très précise de ce qui a manqué ou pas
manquer je pense qu'on nous devons
attendre les conclusions de la réunion
qui aura lieu cet après midi mais oui
ses conclusions sont attendues vous
évoquez les opposants politiques
notamment marine le pen qui demande
l'ouverture d'une enquête mais pas
seulement il ya également stéphane
troussel le président du conseil
départemental de seine saint denis qui
demande l'ouverture d'une enquête est-ce
qu'elle doit être ouvert cette enquête
selon une enquête parlementaire we will
open alors une enquête parlementaire je
pense que marine le pen ça ne lui a pas
échappé que nous étions en campagne
législative donc avant d'attendre que la
représentation nationale soit élu dans
deux semaines trois semaines je pense
qu'il faut tout de suite pouvoir
comprendre ce qui s'est passé c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya cette réunion
ce matin au ministère des sports mais
non pour revenir sur eux stéphane
troussel que je peux complètement
entendre stéphane troussel et président
du département de la seine-saint-denis
et rappelons qu'une partie de
l'échiquier politique dont marine le pen
fait partie a pointé du doigt de manière
très globale et généralisées comme elle
a l'habitude de le faire tous les
habitants de la seine-saint-denis donc
c'est normal qu'ils se soient insurgés
il ya quand même un problème parce que
gérald darmanin lui il a pointé les
fautes des supporters à britannique 1
selon lui eh bien ces incidents sont dus
aux supporters britanniques qui ont
apporté en masse des faux billets mais
on a vu aussi
et jeunes rivaux de saint denis qui se
sont mêlés à l'événement et qui ont
essayé de rentrer et même certains ont
agressé des supporters britanniques leur
ont volé des billets est ce que c'est
quand même le signe d'une violence dans
certains territoires est-ce qui est la
violence en france oui je pense qu'on ne
s'apprend rien aujourd'hui en revanche
je pense que pour arriver précisément en
seine saint denis oui il en est bien
évidemment de seine-saint-denis et ça
c'est évident et ça ne date pas d'hier
pour le coup il faut qu'on puisse y
remédier c'est pour ça qu'on a réinvesti
massivement et quand je dis on gérald
arménien sur le premier quinquennat
massivement dans les forces de l'ordre
pour qu'il ait plus de bleu dans les
rues pour aussi la rénovation des moyens
alloués à nos forces de l'ordre pour
pouvoir agir face à une délinquance qui
est de plus en plus jeune et plus en
plus violente maintenant pour revenir
sur les événements de ce week-end je
pense que pour en arriver à de telles
oeuvres à de tels dégâts il y a quand
même pas qu'une seule population a ciblé
pas qu'un seul phénomène a ciblé c'est à
mon avis et attendons les conclusions
l'ajout de plusieurs phénomènes de
couacs qui se sont passées comment vous
avez jugé la communication de gérald
darmanin qui justement lui a ciblé les
supporters britanniques au risque même
de créer un petit incident diplomatique
avec londres en occultant et bien ces
jeunes des quartiers de saint-denis qui
ont quand même participé à ces violences
si vous parlez du tweet du ministre de
l'intérieur ce tweet a été fait le soir
même ils étaient sur place je n'étais
pas sur place donc c'est très compliqué
pour moi de venir juger a posteriori
d'un tweet maintenant ce qu'on voit
c'est que la ministre des sports met en
place cette réunion ce matin avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes mais
mais je pense que le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est de dépasser le sait la fota mais
de trouver comment faire en sorte que ça
ne se reproduise d'autant que nous avons
on disait les jeux olympiques la coupe
du monde ça vous inquiète qu'on puisse
être ainsi débordé par les événements
sportifs être inquiet relève finit par
empêcher l'action je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous devons être plus
qu'inquiets nous devons être
responsables et donc regarder pleinement
et de façon apaisée pourquoi ça n'a pas
fonctionné ce week-end et avancer
effectivement la ministre des sports est
aussi responsable de l'organisation des
jo 24 alors puisque l'athéna évoqué le
premier grand chantier du gouvernement
la première urgence c'est la lutte pour
le pouvoir d'achat des français la lutte
contre la hausse des prix avec le
gouvernement qui prépare et bien un
paquet de mesures pour le pouvoir
d'achat des français pour l'été
notamment le bouclier tarifaire sur le
gaz électricité la prolongation de la
remise sur le carburant une hausse de
certains minima sociaux l'indexation sur
l'inflation des pensions de retraite est
ce que toutes ces mesures elles sont
assez ambitieuses pour lutter contre
l'inflation alors il ya deux types de
mesures parce que oui l'urgence est de
répondre aux problématiques du moment
des français qui sont immenses la hausse
des prix l'inflation dont vous avez cité
la poursuite d'un certain nombre de
mesures qui habitent ils ont mis en
place à la fin du quinquennat précédent
c'est-à-dire par exemple bouclier
tarifaires mais également la ristourne
sur les carburants il y a aussi une
nouvelle une nouvelle mesure qui sera ce
chèque alimentation ça c'est des mesures
qui sont vocation être ponctuel
maintenant regardons de manière plus
structurelle ce que nous devons
continuer à faire et j'insiste sur le
continu et faire en sorte que le travail
paye mieux et faire aussi en sorte que
les plus fragiles d'entre nous puisse
pouvoir s'en sortir dans des cas comme
cela quand je parle des plus fragiles
bien évidemment il ya les retraités donc
c'est la revalorisation des pensions de
retraite avec l'indexation sur
l'inflation mais également la
revalorisation des minima retraite avec
la réforme de la retraite dont le
président a parlé pendant sa campagne
des présidentielles il ya également les
incitations et j'insiste sur le mot les
incitations auprès des entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent augmenter les salaires
de leurs employés et puis aussi on en
parle très peu mais il faut pas les
oublier ce sont les jeunes nos étudiants
elisabeth bande a bien pointé le fait
que dès cet été nous devons avoir des
mesures très précises pour accompagner
nos étudiants alors vous dites il faut
que le travail paye mieux pourquoi tout
simplement ne pas augmenter les salaires
et notamment le smic à 1500 euros comme
le propose jean luc mélenchon et
nulle part la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale je pense que la
démagogie vais finir par tuer notre
démocratie et notre bon sens cdma lundi
commentait le salaire comment mais je
sais pas que c'est démagogique
d'augmenter les salaires mais vous le
savez très bien on n'augmente pas les
salaires comme ça d'un claquement de
doigts ça ne se décide pas comme ça et
ça peut avoir des incidences extrêmement
néfaste simplement dire en anglais le
smic soit plus de simplement dire
augmenter les salaires sans rappeler aux
ça peut aussi avoir une incidence sur
les marges que se font les entreprises
marges nécessaires pour qu'elle se
développe pour qu'elles embauchent et
qu'elles maintiennent leur niveau
d'employabilité donc finalement ça
pourra avoir une conséquence très
importante sur le chômage qui rappelons
le nous avons permis de le baisser comme
jamais auparavant ce que nous disons
c'est que plutôt que de pointer du doigt
les entreprises parce que finalement
c'est ce que jean luc mélenchon fait
indirectement dans cette proposition
c'est les inciter les accompagner a
effectivement pouvoir augmenter les
salaires et on le voit qu'elles le font
elles le font pourquoi parce qu'elles
ont intérêt à faire en sorte que leurs
salariés soient mieux payés qu'elle se
sente mieux que l'ours à la yaris lente
mais dans leur emploi et qu'il reste et
alors en tout cas sur certaines
catégories d'entreprises qui font des
profits notamment les groupes pétroliers
avec cette période de hausse des prix du
carburant et ce qu'il faut rester dans
ces incitations ou est-ce qu'il faut
être plus ferme et taxer les profits des
grands groupes pétroliers alors je pense
que sur ce sujet là nous pouvons pas
penser au niveau du marché européen et
c'est pour ça que j'insiste sur
l'importance de l'europe parce
qu'effectivement le marché européen est
colossal et permet peut-être d'avoir
effectivement des leviers d'action
vis-à-vis de ces grands groupes
pétroliers je pense que c'est en
discussion mais c'est un sujet que nous
devons regarder de façon très claire
censée au delà de la france au niveau de
l'europe la politique des chèques qu'on
évoquait l instant qu alexandre évoqué l
instant est ce qu'elle ne met pas en
péril les finances publiques alors il y
avait là je vais reprendre un terme qui
a été employé par le nouveau ministre du
budget qui est vrai à la talent il y à
des économies qui rapporte et des
dépenses il a des économies pardon qui
coûte et des dépenses qui qui rapporte
pourquoi parceque il s'agit pas
simplement de faire des chèques comme on
peut l'entendre notamment sur
l'échiquier à droite nude du côté des
républicains
aider les français à protéger leur
pouvoir d'achat aider les français à
boucler non plus leurs fins de mois mais
leur fin de semaine voir leur deux jours
c'est dieu c'est du devoir public le
responsable politique qui est emmanuel
macron doit le faire c'est pour ça que
je sais sur des mesures ponctuelles sur
tout ce qui peut avoir sur les boucliers
des prix ni sur les prix mais également
des mesures plus structurelles sur le
fait que le salaire et les l'emploi paye
mieux justement sur les prix alors il ya
le bouclier tarifaire pour le gaz
électricité qui va être prolongée par le
gouvernement est ce qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin et bloquer les prix de
certains produits nécessitent de
nécessité comme le propose jean luc
mélenchon je pense que avant de regarder
à bloquer les prix parce que quand on
bloque les prix s'est levé pain
est ce qu'il le deal d'ailleurs hier il
a été interrogé sur sa il ne sait pas
dire si c'est ponctuel ça va durer
longtemps à partir de quand il le fait
là l'urgence c'est de répondre tout de
suite maintenant à la difficulté des
français effectivement on le voit que
grâce aux mesures qui ont été mises en
place sur notamment les prix des
carburants sur les prix de l'énergie
nous avons pu avoir une inflation
maintenu contenu par rapport à nos pays
européens donc nous voyons que ça
fonctionne donc je pense que l'urgence
c'est de mettre en place une mesure de
poursuivre une mesure qui a montré
qu'elle fonctionnait alors le
gouvernement en tout cas a en tout cas
en tête et bien certaines économies à
faire et notamment sur le système des
retraites avec la réforme des retraites
et le recul de l'âge de départ les
concertations ont commencé la semaine
dernière entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats est ce que ce recul à l'âge de
départ à 65 ans n'est plus un totem est
en tout cas on n'est même plus sûr de la
teinte pour le gouvernement alors ce qui
est sûr c'est que la réforme des
retraites voulue par le président de la
république ce n'est pas simplement une
réforme sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est bien plus complexe que
cela et c'est bien plus puissant que
cela en réalité il s'agit tout d'abord
de faire en sorte que les pensions de
retraite et un minimum qu'il n'y plus
une pension de retraite en dessous de
1100 euros que le système soit également
égalitaire plus universel et qui
prennent bien en compte les spécificités
des carrières les carrières longues les
carrières pénibles effectivement pour
mettre en place cela gaza un coup et
soit on décide de le faire peser sur les
actifs or ça pose encore le sujet du
travail qui doit payer mieux ou sur
effectivement le système de retraite tel
qu'il existe aujourd'hui par répartition
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle il
y aura un décalage et je dis bien
progressif de l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui va se faire à raison de
trois ou quatre mois par an avec une
clause de revoyure pour voir si nous
devons aller plus loin ou alors si nous
devons en rester là et donc selon vous
est ce qu'il faut s'accrocher à cet âge
de 65 ans ou vraiment on voit en 2028 et
on fait jouer ou pas la clause de
revoyure points de rechargement l'âge
c'est quand même le point d'achoppement
bel et bien son travail c'est comme ça
il ne s'agit pas d'un totem sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite mais bien de se
dire qu'aujourd'hui notre système de
solidarité est un trésor nous sommes
tous convaincus que nous devons le
garder nous devons le préserver par
contre si nous devons le préserver et le
sauvegarder il faut être responsable et
se dire qu'aujourd'hui nous allons dans
le mur donc allons nous laisser comme
système de solidarité à nos enfants et à
nos petits-enfants donc encore une fois
regardons dans la globalité oui il va
falloir bouger cet âge de départ à la
retraite voyons le curseur jusqu'où nous
pouvons aller de façon raisonnable mais
nous devons y aller alors pris ce qui
était venue évoquer la campagne des
élections législatives et notamment la
campagne de la majorité présidentielle
avec d'abord une question où est le
président la république pour mener
campagne pour aller chercher des députés
pour faire sa majorité le président de
la république et à sa tâche le crois que
ça vous a pas échappé il ya notamment
des sujets nationaux le sujet de ce
projet de loi qui veut travailler
notamment avec elizabeth demandé
l'ensemble des ministres qui ont eu leur
feuille de route mais également sur des
sujets européens internationaux
l'inflation en fait partie mais
également je crois qu'il ya une guerre
en ukraine en ce moment et ça nous a pas
échappé que ce week-end notamment il ya
eu des discussions des échanges entre le
chancelier allemand la france est
également vladimir poutine il a
rencontré luc en vigueur des futures
nous avons fait une réunion
effectivement nous avons eu une grande
journée à aubervilliers où l'ensemble
des candidats étaient présents étaient
réunies dont 50 % étaient des primo dans
les investitures aux législatives nous
continuons ce que nous avons fait en
2017 et le président de la république
nous a rejoints en fin de journée est-ce
que vous admettez quand même que cette
campagne des élections législatives
notamment du côté de l'ama on était
présidentielle elle a un peu du mal à
démarrer on a entendu trois semaines le
nouveau gouvernement la cei il est en
place on sent qu'il ya quand même pas
d'effet de renouveau avec notamment la
féra bad qui est un peu plombé le début
de ce nouveau gouvernement est ce que
vous voilà vous êtes un peu dans
peut-être l'impatience que ça commence
vraiment la campagne pour vous je peux
vous dire que j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'impression qu'elle n'ait pas commencé
à la campagne chez vous venez de le dire
en début d'émission je suis moi-même
candidate et si aujourd'hui j'ai des
baskets c'est pas parce que c'est c'est
plus agréable au pied c'est parce que
après je vais aller sur le terrain comme
la majorité grande majorité de
l'ensemble des candidats nous sommes sur
le terrain non pas depuis aujourd'hui
date officielle de lancement de la
campagne des législatives mais depuis
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines donc
oui cette campagne se fait peut-être
moins et je vous la corde dans les
médias mais elle se fait là où c'est
finalement peut-être le plus important
c'est sur le terrain à hauteur d'homme
nous sommes 577 candidats investis nous
sommes investies sur le terrain auprès
des français et des françaises parce que
j'en suis sûr ça la campagne des
présidentielles nous avions un slogan
qui s'appelait avec vous mais plus qu'un
slogan c'est une méthode et nous la
mettons en place dès cette campagne des
législatives alors en tout cas il ya un
candidat et ancien ministre qui est un
petit peu de mal dans cette campagne des
élections législatives c'est jean michel
blanquer en fait remise de l'éducation
nationale et selon un sondage paru dans
le journal du dimanche d'hier et bien il
pourrait ne pas se qualifier au second
tour dans sa circonscription du loiret à
montargis le rassemblement national
pourrait même emporté cette
circonscription à quoi c'est dû selon
vous est-ce que c'est du est bien au
fait qu'il a un peu été parachuté dans
le département du loiret où est-ce que
c'est dû à son bilan en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale alors
ça je ne pourrai pas vous le dire parce
qu'avec des si je pense que je ferai le
monde et ce serait de temps en temps
intéressant à regarder ce que j'aimerais
rappeler essai de manière très simple
c'est que oui les sondages sont
importants parce qu'ils permettent
d'avoir une tendance à l'instant t et ça
permet de se projeter ça permet
effectivement d'avoir certaines
démarches maintenant je le rappelle
aussi les sondages ne vote pas ce sont
les gens qui votent il nous reste encore
deux semaines de campagne avant le
premier tour chaque heure chaque moment
sur le terrain compte les français
jugeront au final et nous respecterons
le choix des français le choix des urnes
justement qu'est ce qu'on vous dit sur
le terrain est ce que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de questions notamment sur la
sphère damien abad qui est accusé de
viol l'ancien des républicains et qui
est candidat dans l'ain est ce que voilà
ça à préoccupe les gens sur le terrain
parce que c'est pas un peu votre frein
sur cette campagne législative et
notamment quand on est candidat femmes
ainsi oui je peux tout à fait entendre
alors déjà en tant que candidate femme
et en tant que femme tout court je peux
vous dire que oui il faut que la parole
des femmes puissent continuer à se
libérer comme nous avons permis de le
faire au cours des cinq dernières années
puisque nous le répétons le la priorité
de ce quinquennat reste elle est
renouvelée la libération de la parole
des femmes et la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
maintenant pour que cette parole des
femmes puissent est le mieux entendu le
mieux traité et le mieux également
accueilli et bien il faut que ça se
fasse dans le cadre de l'état de droit
le tribunal médiatique ne permet pas à
cette parole des femmes de se libérer
voire même elles ont fini par à devenir
dangereuse donc sur ce point là je pense
que on s'accorde à se dire que l'état
doit d'être respectée et que oui elle
permet la libération de la parole des
femmes est en réalité ce que je vous dis
c'est ce que j'entends aussi sur le
terrain est ce que j'entends surtout sur
le terrain c'est aidez nous à boucler
nos fins de mois aidez nous à répondre à
nos problématiques du quotidien et donc
pour cela nous avons besoin que le
président la république le gouvernement
puisse être dans l'action sauf que nous
voyons aussi de part et d'autre et là je
vais dire de manière générale sur nos
oppositions c'est qu'il ya une volonté
encore une fois malheureusement pour
certaines de dire nous voulons montrer
que le président de la république va
échouer or si le président de la
république échoue c'est la france qui
échouent la france qui échoue à répondre
aux problématiques des françaises et des
français et donc ça nous l'entendons
donc oui nous sommes dans une démarche
d'action nous ne sommes pas dans une
démarche d'obstruction nous sommes
volontaires pour qu'il y ait un débat
donc et les oppositions soit bien
présente mais opposition pour permettre
de construire permettent d'avancer cas
permettent de ralentir justement un mot
sur l'opposition et sur vos adversaires
dans cette campagne des élections
législatives avec à la nuque l'union de
la gauche la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale finalement est ce
que jean luc mélenchon il n'a pas gagné
la bataille de la communication avec ce
fameux slogan élisez moi premier
ministre est-ce que c'est pas l'homme de
ces législatives finalement c'est celui
qu'on entend plus
c'est celui qu'on entend plus c'est un
très bel orateur est vraiment il parle
très bien il enchante
maintenant c'est un magnifique
liquidateur aussi je pense que
n'oublions pas de regarder ce qui est
dans le fond des propos et de la
démarche de jean luc mélenchon quelle
est sa position avec la nuque sur la
laïcité quelle est la position sur le
nucléaire quelle est sa position sur
l'environnement en général quelle est sa
position sur la proche que nous devons
avoir avec nos forces de l'ordre dans ce
nom s'est tenu que nous avons un bloody
où le gars de tout et n'importe quoi et
ça laisse présager pas le mieux pas le
meilleur pour demain pour être dans
cette capacité d'action encore une fois
que réclament les français la
communication c'est bien l'action pour
les autres c'est encore mieux mais en
même temps la majorité présidentielle
elle va de l'enfant socialiste françois
rebsamen à l'ancien les républicains
avec woerth au delà des et merci de le
mettre merci de souligner au delà des
étiquettes politiques ce sont des hommes
de conviction des hommes et des femmes
de conviction qui se réunissent sous
l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle pourquoi parce que nous
avons une ligne très claire une ligne
cohérente c'est que le socle sur lequel
nous sommes unis c'est le projet du
président de la république il peut
exister des nuances mais ces nuances ne
sont pas là pour mettre à mal le projet
elles sont là pour renforcer ce projet
or ce que nous voyons au sein de la
nuque c'est qu' il n'y a pas de ligne
claire il n'y a pas de projet il n'y a
que des idées qui s'opposent les unes et
aux autres demain c'est comme ça qu'ils
espèrent construire une majorité une
majorité qui n'est pas capable
aujourd'hui de s'entendre va demain
s'entendre sur les bancs de l'assemblée
excusez moi j'ai un peu du mal à y
croire une dernière question justement
pour que ça soit bien clair dans notre
esprit si on prend l'hypothèse que dans
certaines circonscriptions il ya des
second tour entre un candidat de la
nuque et un candidat du rassemblement
national qui la majorité présidentielle
doit-elle soutenir doit-elle rares
alliés ou alors est-ce que c'est le ni
ni eh bien ça va se faire non je suis
pas favorable au ni ni il faut il faut
aller voter il faut aller voter avec
conviction et dans une démarche
citoyenne maintenant soyons très clairs
je viens de vous le dire la nuque ça va
c'est c'est tout ils sont m donc je
pense que tout ça devra se regarder au
cas par cas
circonscription par circonscription et
je pense et je l'espère que en face de
chacun de ces candidats que ce soit la
nuque ou le rn ou d'ailleurs un autre
candidat parce qu'il ya aussi des listes
des candidats citoyens sans étiquette
politique il y aura un candidat de la
majorité présidentielle au second tour
donc au cas par cas pas forcément de
front républicain anti rassemblement
national du côté de la nuque ça veut
rien dire je pense qu'il faut regarder
ce qui se passe mais encore une fois le
cas où il y aurait un candidat fn et un
candidat nulle au second tour je le
souhaite et là qui est un souhait très
personnelle qu'il y aura en réalité pas
ce cas de figure et qu'il y aura chaque
fois un candidat de la majorité
présidentielle la question fabrice
l'abstention ou inquiète oui vous vous
intéressez beaucoup à ces questions de
participations notamment dans le cadre
d'une école qui s'appelle civile un
pacte avec la mobilisation des jeunes
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas là
aujourd'hui avec les jeunes en effet
orienté alors effectivement j'ai j'ai
cofondé il ya cinq ans justement au
lendemain du nul à la présidence de 2010
est une école d'engagement citoyen
puisque effectivement c'est facile de
dire engagez-vous mais s'engager c'est
compliqué c'est difficile c'est pas
souvent évident et aujourd'hui je
considère que nous avons peut-être un
tort c'est de considérer que les partis
politiques sont des vieilleries à bouger
pas du tout les partis politiques sont
des endroits où on apprend aussi
l'engagement on apprend à se repérer sur
un échiquier politique qu'on peut faire
évolué qu'on peut faire bouger au gré
des actualités au gré des contextes mais
qui sont extrêmement importants donc moi
ce que j'invite les jeunes à faire les
jeunes et les moins jeunes d'ailleurs
c'est à venir franchir la porte des
partis politiques parce que c'est là
aussi on apprend à s'engager on apprend
à s'engager et je le rappelle pas tout
seul accompagné remercie beaucoup prisca
thévenot d'avoir été notre invité
politique ce matin
[Musique]